AND GUYS STEP UP AND RESPOND.
SO IF YOU'RE THE MEMPHIS
GRIZZLIES, BE WELL AWARE OF THE
FACT THIS GAME IS FAR FROM OVER.
>> Jeff: I WOULD SAY, TOO, JUAN
TOSCANO-ANDERSON, WITHOUT
IGUODALA, TOSCANO-ANDERSON CAN
FILL THAT ROLE TO SOME DEGREE.
HE HASN'T PLAYED A LOT.
OTTO PORTER, BUT THEY CAN SCORE
ENOUGH.
TO ME IT IMPACTS THEM MORE
DEFENSIVELY.
>> Mike: CURRY, SHOT CLOCK AT 7.
ANDERSON ON HIM.
WELL DEFENDED BY ANDERSON.
CURRY TRIES AGAIN, GETS INSIDE,
SHOT BLOCKED.
MELTON WITH THE REJECTION.
MELTON ALLEY-OOP TO MORANT.
POOLE ON THE CROSSOVER GETS
INSIDE, LAYUP BLOCKED BY CLARKE.
THE PASS AHEAD, PORTER ABLE TO
RUN IT DOWN.
BRANDON CLARKE WITH A TERRIFIC
DEFENSIVE PLAY.
PORTER, KUMINGA, LAYUP, MISSED
IT.
BACK TO KUMINGA ON THE
DEFLECTION.
AND THE SHOT CLOCK TURNED OFF.
NO FOULS TO GIVE FOR THE
WARRIORS.